[تصفيق]
ابتسم دائما انا رجل سعيد فانا محظوظ
بانني العب في نادي رائع ولعائله رائعه
لدي اربعه اولاد وانا بصحه جيده واملك كل
شيء
الفائز بخمس جوائز كره ذهبيه ومحطما الرقم
القياسي استحق الجائزه هذا العام كنت
استحق اكثر العام الفائت انا سعيد وما
مجموعه 29 جائزه وطنيه انه فوزي الاول في
دوري الابطال شعوري مذهل كما تعلمون انها
لحظه رائعه واكثر من 700 هدف خلال مسيرته
الكرويه وهذا جزء مما حققه خلال مسيرته
الكرويه الاحترافيه العالميه على مدى 17
عاما يعرف كل ارقام ريال مدريد القياسيه
ولا يزال يحرز الاهداف لاعبون مذهلون
ساعده ابداعه وسرعته ورؤيته الحالمه في ان
يصبح واحدا من اعظم اللاعبين في التاريخ
استعد دائما بالطريقه نفسها لا يهم الفريق
الذي سالعب ضده يبقى تركيزي بالمستوى نفسه
دائما
من فريق سبورتنج لشبونه البرتغالي الى
مانشستر يونايتد الانجليزي الى ريال مدريد
الاسباني مرحبا يا
مدريد والان فريق يوفنتوس الايطالي اظهر
رونالدو انه لا يستطيع اي شيء ابقاء فما
يزال يقدم اداء يستحق الجوائز اسبوعا بعد
اسبوع انه واحد من اعظم لاعبين في التاريخ
ولا احد يستطيع الاعتراض على ذلك ابدا
شاهدوا رحلتنابغه البرتغال وقصه حصوله على
لقب بطل العالم
انا سعيد لكن لا يستطيع احد التنبؤ انه
الرجل صاحب لقب سي ار 7 اريد الاستمرار
على هذا النحو عاما بعد عام انه
كريستيانو رونالدو
[موسيقى]
ولد كريستيانو رونالدو دوس سانتوس افيرو
في الخامس من فبراير عام
1985 وهو الاصغر بين اخوته الاربعه كانت
والدته تعمل الطاهيه وكان والده بستانيا
المدينه
عاشت عائلته في مدارا التي اصبحت الان
وجهه سياحيه ذات شعبيه كبيره وهي جزيره
صغيره قباله الساحل البرتغالي لكن في
العام
1985 كانت مدارس تعيش في فقر متقع ويسكنها
مجتمع صغير جدا ذكر رونالدو ان عائلته
عاشت حياه متواضعه خاليه من البفخ والرخاء
بكل تاكيد ولد كريستيانو في عائله كبيره
جدا في جزيره ماديرا وكانت عائلته تعيش في
فونشال لا اعتقد انه يمكن القول انما ديرا
تقع في منتصف المحيط الاطلسي فهذا غير
صحيح لكنها بعيده جدا عن بر البرتغال
الرئيسي فذلك لا يشبه الترعرع في لشبونه
او بورتو او احدى المدن الرئيسيه بل
الحياه فيها مختلفه جدا عن البر البرتغالي
الرئيسي فهو مجتمع صغير جدا وكان رونالدو
يلعب كره القدم هناك مع عائلته واصدقائه
في شوارع مادارا وانخرط مع النادي المحلي
كان والده يعمل مدير معدات بدوام جزئي لدى
النادي المحلي لذا ولد في عائله لها موطئ
قدم في اللعبه اذا تربى على يد اب عاشق
لكره القدم وهو امر شديد الاهميه بالطبع
بالنسبه الى كريستيانو الصغير حين بدا
يشحذ مهاراته في شوارع فونشال كان في نادي
الشباب المحلي يكتسب مهاراته الكرويه وكان
يشعر كانه على بعد ملايين الكيلومترات عن
اضواء الانديه الاوروبيه الساطعه التي
يطمح لان يلعب معها
في سن الثامنه انضم رونالدو الى فريق
الشباب الاول له وهو فريق اندورينا حيث
كان والده يعمل مدير معدات بدوام جزئي
اصبحت كره القدم الان هوسا بالنسبه اليه
وكان يمارسها في الشوارع والملعب على
السواء في سن العاشره انتقل الى واحد من
اكبر النوادي في ماديرا وهو نادي ناسيونال
لكن اثناء اللعب مع النادي اكتشفه مكتشف
مواهب كره قدم وفي سن 12 تم اختياره ليقدم
تجربه اداء للانضمام الى الفريق البرتغالي
سبورتنج لشبونه
اعتقد ان موهبه رونالدو الفذه كانت واضحه
منذ سن مبكره كانت واضحه لعائلته وزملائه
في الفريق وجميع من حوله وعلى الرغم من ان
ماديرا بعيده جدا عن بر البرتغال الرئيسي
الا ان النوادي الكبيره في بر البرتغال
الرئيسي كانت على درايه بما يحصل وكانوا
متحمسين للذهاب والاستعلام عن شخص يتسبب
بكل هذه الضجه حتى لو كان في جزيره ماديرا
الواقعه في عرض المحيط الاطلسي وعندما كان
رونالدو في سن 12 دعاه فريق سبورتنج الى
لشبونه هل يمكنكم تخيل حجم الانتقال من
جزيره ماديرا الصغيره جدا والتي تعد مجرد
بركه صغيره جدا ليجد فجاه انه اخذ الى
سبورتنج الذي لديه اكاديميه خاصه به
بالقرب من لشبونه وانتقل كريستيانو الى
البر الرئيسي وهو صبي في سن الثانيه عشره
او 13 الامر يشبه الهجره الى بلد مختلف
بالكامل يتكلم اللغه نفسها انه البلد نفسه
لكن الطابع مختلف جدا عن ط وجد رونالدو
نفسه وهو في سن 12 يعيش في العاصمه
البرتغاليه ومنظما الى اكاديميه سبورتنج
لشبونه هذه الى مجتمع ذاك النادي الكبير
البعيد كل البعد عن كل ما كان معتادا عليه
وتوجب عليه العيش مستعينا بذكائه وموهبته
وبالطبع كان يتمتع بالموهبه الكافيه ليلمع
نجمه على الفور لكن لم يكن الانتقال الى
البر الرئيسي سهلا على رونالدو فقد عن ذلك
ان عليه العيش بعيدا عن عائلته وذكر ان
الايام الاولى كانت صعبه وانه شعر بالحنين
الى الديار كل يوم لكن استمر رونالدو
بتطوير مسيرته مع فريق سبورتنج لشبونه كان
رونالدو لاعبا محوريا ضمن فريق سبورتنج
لشبونه للشباب كان تنافسيا وماهرا جدا
وكانت موهبته واضحه لكل من حضر المباريات
كما ذكر زملائه في الفريق ان قدرته
واسلوبه في اللعب كان مختلفين عن كل ما
راوه سابقا
كان يملك ميزه خاصه وكان من الواضح انه
نجم اخذ في الصعود لوحظت موهبته هذه مبكرا
جدا من قبل فريق سبورتنج ولم يمضي وقت
طويل قبل ان تبدا مسيرته بالازدهار
عندما كنت صبيا صغيرا كنت اشعر دائما
انني مميز وليس من وجهه نظري فقط بل رايت
الناس ينظرون الي بطريقه مختلفه لانني
اعتقد انني كنت مختلفا عن بقيه اللاعبين
كان موسم
2003 لرونالدو مع فريق سبورتنج لشبونه هو
ما جعله يتصدر الصفحات في البرتغال حقا
كما بدا اداؤه يجتذب الكثير من الاهتمام
العالمي مع اقتراب نهايه الموسم انتشرت
شائعه انتقاله في جميع ارجاء اوروبا اظهر
ممثلون لليفربول وارسنال وبرشلونه اهتماما
بتوقيع عقد مع المراهق النابغه لكن خلال
مباراه ما قبل الموسم في العام 2003 اثبت
رونالدو حقا انه لاعب مميز
كانت المباراه ضد مانشستر يونايتد
المباراه التي ستغير حياته في شكل جذري
اذا احد اهم التواريخ على الاطلاق في قصه
رونالدو هو السادس من اغسطس عام 2003
عندما تم افتتاح ملعب سبورتنج الجديد ملعب
واستضافوا مباراه وديه ضد مانشستر يونايتد
المباراه الاولى على الاطلاق للاحتفال
بافتتاح الملعب وكان رونالدو قد انضم الى
فريق سبورتنج الاول عند نهايه الموسم
السابق وكانت تلك ساحه جديده مباراه ضد
مانشستر يونايتد وكان مذهلا في تلك
المباراه الوديه ووفق الروايات خلال
الاستراحه بين الشوطين كان اللاعبون
مانشستر يونايتد قد ذهلوا بمناورات هذا
الفتى الذي لا يعرفون عنه اي شيء تقريبا
الى درجه انهم قالوا لمدير مانشستر
يونايتد عندما دخلوا غرفه تبديل الملابس
في الاستراحه عليك ان توقع عقدا مع هذا
الفتى واجه مدافع مانشستر يونايتد المحترف
مصاعب كبيره خلال دقائق الخمس والاربعين
الاولى بسبب اداء رونالدو الاستثنائي ووفق
الروايات ذهب اليكس فيرجسون الى مدير
معدات فريق يونايتد وطلب منه ان يعثر على
بيتر كينيون المدير التنفيذي للنادي كي
يبدا المفاوضات مع فريق سبورتنج على الفور
خلال الشوط الثاني للحرص على ان يوقع هذا
الفتى عقدا مع مانشستر يونايتد قبل ان
يفعل اي نادي اخر في الواقع كان رونالدو
قد حاول التقرب قليلا من نادي ليفربول حيث
قال كم سيكون سعيدا وكم سيكون مشرفا ان
ينضم الى نادي عريق كهذا كان فريق ارسنال
قد التقى بوكيل رونالدو لكن حرص فيرجس
بناء على اقاويل لاعبيه على التوقيع معه
خلال الخمس والاربعين دقيقه في الشوط
الثاني من تلك المباراه الوديه الى درجه
انهم حصلوا على رونالدو بالفعل مع انطلاق
صفاره نهايه المباراه قال اليكس فيريكسون
كريستيانو اريدك ان تاتي للاعب مع مانشستر
يونايتد وستلعب نسبه 50% من المباريات ذلك
اشعرني بالراحه قلت رائع بالنسبه الي كشاب
في الثامنه عشره المشاركه في 50% من
المباريات هو امر لا يصدق لهذا السبب
اتخذت القرار وساعدني جورج على اتخاذ
القرار بالطبع وكلمات السير اليكسون
الاخيره كانت الاساسيه لموافقه على توقيع
مع مانشستر يونايتد
اصبح مانشستر يونايتد موطنه الجديد وهي
لحظه جوهريه في حياه رونالدو فرصه لاثبات
نفسه في المسرح العالمي من خلال اللعب مع
نادي عريق كهذا وعقبا انضمامه الى النادي
منح رونالدو قميصا رقم 7 وهو الرقم الذي
ارتداه نجوم يونايتد الايقونات مثل
كان الضغط هائلا وكانت التوقعات المعلقه
على ابن الثامنه عشره كبيره علينا ان
نتذكر انه ابان وصوله الى مانشستر يونايتد
كان ديفيد بيكهام قد ترك الفريق منذ وقت
قصير لينضم الى ريال مدريد وكان بيكم
النجم اللامعه وسط النجوم اذا كانت كوكبه
مانشستر يونايتد تفتقد احدا نجومها اكبر
كوكب فيها ان صح التعبير نحن نعرف الان
بالطبع ان رونالدو اتى لاحقا وطغى حتى على
انجازات ديفيد بيكم في اولد ترافورد اما
حينها فقد اتى كمراهق النحيل البدن اغلى
مراهق على الاطلاق في كره القدم
الانجليزيه كان ثمن صفقته مليون جنيه
استرليني ونصف المليون تقريبا وماذا فعل
رونالدو ارتدا قميصه بيكم ذا الرقم 7 وهذا
يخبرنا الكثير عن طبيعه رونالدو ففي تلك
السن كان مستعدا لارتداء القميص رقم سبعه
الذي لم يرتده بيكم فقط بل ايرك كانت تونه
ايضا انه القميص الايقوني في ملعب اولدي
ترافورد وكانت الخطوه الاولى التي اقدم
عليها رونالدو هي قبول ذلك الرقم وهذا
يتطلب الكثير من الثقه بالنفس في السادسه
عشر من اغسطس عام 2003 لعب رونالدو
مباراته الاولى مع فريق مانشستر يونايتد
على ارضه ضد فريق بولتون وفي الدقيقه
الستين دخل المباراه على التصفيق مع
الوقوف حيث استبدل نيكيبات طوال الجزء
التالي من المباراه هتف المشجعون باسم
رونالدو فقد بث طاقه جديده في الفريق
اعتقد ان خطه يونايتد فيما يتعلق برونالدو
كانت على الارجح ان يحاولوا تقديمه الى
الدوري الانجليزي بالتدريج فهذا بلد جديد
وكان يتعلم لغه جديده ببراعه كبيره واعتقد
ان خطه كانت ان يحاولوا التعامل معه
بطريقه نفسها التي اتبعوها مع وهي
الاستعانه به بتحفظ لكن لا يمكن فعل ذلك
مع رونالدو قال جورج بيست ان مباراه
رونالدو الاولى مع مانشستر كانت واحده من
اكثر المباريات حماسه مما شاهده في حياته
فعندما يقول جورج هذا عن لاعب صاعد سينتبه
اليه الجميع حكما انتهت المباراه بفوز
مانشستر يونايتد باربعه اهداف نظيفه ومع
ان رونالدو لم يسجل هدفا الا انه ساعد في
تقديم الكره نحو المرمى مرات عده بفضل
سرعته ومهارته العاليه في المناوره وقدم
تمريره حاسمه في احراز هدف يونايتد الثاني
في ذلك الوقت كانت قدرات رونالدو
الاستثنائيه قد بدات تبرز بوضوح ولياقته
البدنيه بالطبع التي عمل على تطويرها طوال
مسيرته يتمتع بقوه هائله وقدمين سريعتين
الى حد لا يصدق قدماه كيديه ساحر قدرته
على تغيير سرعته مذهله وسرعته القصوى لا
تصدق كان قد بدا حينها يطغى على انجازات
على الجناح الايسر مع مانشستر يونايتد
فبات كريستيانو رونا يقدم ذلك واكثر على
الجناح الايمن مجموعه مهاراته لا تصدق
واصبح يحرج فعلا بعض افضل المدافعين في
الدوري الانجليزي الممتاز اسبوعا بعد
اسبوع بفضل مناوراته ومهاراته وسرعته
وقوته التي لم يروا مثيلها ولم يختبروها
ابدا من قبل ولم يستطيعوا مجاراتها بسرعه
كبيره اصبح رونالدو واحدا من افضل
اللاعبين في الدوري الجديد في الموسم
الاول لرونالدو مع مانشستر يونايتد تصدر
اسمه العناوين على الرغم من حقيقه انه كان
يلعب 50% من المباريات فقط لكن بعد ثلاثه
اشهر فقط مع الفريق الاول سجل رونالدو
هدفه الاول ضد بورتس سدد هذا الهدف من
خلال ركله حره مذهله تخطط حارس المرمى
بسرعه كبيره واستقرت في الزاويه اليمنى
العلويه للمرمى لم يثبت رونالدو انه لاعب
عظيم من كل النواحي فحسب بل استعرض ايضا
دقته الكبيره في تسديد الركلات الحره
[تصفيق]
فورد يهدف لصاحب الرقم 7 الجديد انهى
رونالدو موسمه الاول في الدوري الانجليزي
الممتاز كفائزا بكاس الاتحاد الانجليزي
بالتغلب على فريق ميلول في المباراه
النهائيه ساعد رونالدو في تسديد الهدف
الافتتاحي الذي الهم الفريق نحو الفوز كان
في الثامنه عشره لاعبا اساسيا في يونايتد
كما فاز بالجائزه الاولى في انجلترا
[موسيقى]
في مطلع عام 2005 قدم رونالدو بعضا من
افضل مبارياته مع يونايتد على الاطلاق في
مباراتهم ضد استون فيلا سدد رونالدو هدفا
وتمريره حاسمه غيارات طاقه الفريق جذريا
وساعده في الفوز بثلاثه اهداف مقابل هدف
واحد على ارضه المباراه الثانيه البارزه
له كانت ضد اكبر منافسا ليونايتد انذاك
وهو فريق وارسنال بث رونالدو في هذه
المباراه ايضا طاقه جديده في الفريق واحرز
هدفين مساعدا يونايتد في الفوز على منافسه
الاكبر باربعه اهداف مقابل هدفين على ارض
الخصم كان رونالدو قد بدا يصبح اللاعب
المفضل لدى الجماهير في مانشستر واكثر
لاعب معروف في كره القدم الانجليزيه لكن
مع اقتراب كاس العالم 2006 تحول من محبوب
الجماهير الى شرير في مباراه واحده
مع بدء كاس العالم للعام 2006 كان
كريستيانو رونالدو بالطبع قد اصبح معروفا
في ارجاء انجلترا واوروبا ايضا كواحدا من
اعظم اللاعبين في العالم وكانت هناك حاله
الترقب هائله لما سيقدمه في كاس العالم
وكان هناك بالطبع صراع محتدم بين انجلترا
والبرتغال في ربع النهائي رونالدو ضد روني
زميله في مانشستر يونايتد وتصدمت القارتان
في شكل حتمي ولا ينسى بالتاكيد
اذا انتهى الامر بان ارتكب روني الذي كان
دوما سريع الغضب مخالفه عندما داس على
المدافع البرتغالي ريكاردو كار فاليو ووقع
في مشكله بالطبع وعلى الفور هب رونالدو
للضغط على الحكم كي يخرج زميله في النادي
من المباراه في شكل الرئيسي رونالدو ليس
غبيا وكان يعرف ان قدره المنتخب الانجليزي
على الفوز تتناقص كثيرا من دون روني ما
يزيد فرصه البرتغال بالتاهل للنهائي في
شكل كبير وعلى الرغم من ان الحكم صرح
لاحقا ان روني اخرج من المباراه بسبب
المخالفه وليس لاي سبب اخر الا انه بدا ان
قياده رونالدو لحمله تحريض الحكم نيابه عن
المنتخب البرتغالي هي ما اقنعت الحكم
باخراج روني من المباراه ومن ثم الغمزه
التي لا يستطيع احد النسيانها والتي
التقطت على الكاميرا بينما كانت البطاقه
الحمراء تشهر في وجه روني وكان يخرج من
الملعب بخطى متفاقله غمز رونالدو بعينه
ناظرا لمقاعد بدلاء البرتغال واقتنع
الرجال والنساء الانجليز بان رونالدو هو
الذي تسبب بخروج روني توا
وقد تطلب التجاوز ذلك الموسم قوه شخصيه
هائله من قبل رونالدو حتما حيث تحول الى
شرير الدوري الانجليزي الممتاز في شكل
مبالغ فيه رغم الكره الموجه نحو رونالدو
بعد عودته من كاس العالم 2006 كان موسم
2006 الفين 2007 مليئا بلحظات محطمه
للارقام القياسيه بالنسبه اليه حيث كسر
حاجز العشرين هدفا للمره الاولى واحرز
هدفه الخمسين مع مانشستر يونايتد وفاز
بجائزه افضل لاعب شاب للعام وجائزه لعب
العام من اتحاد نقاد كره القدم وعلاوه على
ذلك كله ساعد يونايتد على الفوز بلقب
الدوري الانجليزي الممتاز
مع نهايه عام 2007 تم ترشيح رونالدو بفضل
مسيرته المذهله مع يونايتد الفوز بجائزه
افضل لاعب كره قدم في العالم متنافسا مع
كاكا وميسي كما تم ترشيحه للفوز بجائزه
الكره الذهبيه الاولى لكن للاسف حصل على
المركز الثاني امام الفائز كاكا وعلى
المركز الثالث في جائزه افضل لاعب كره قدم
في العالم في سن الثالثه والعشرين فقط
اصبح واحدا من افضل اللاعبين في العالم
وكان عام 2008 سيكون مليئا اكثر
بالانجازات بالنسبه الى رونالدو
اذا اردنا العثور على موسم رونالدو الذهبي
في اولد ترافورد من المرجح ان يكون موسم
2007 2008 والمفارقه في الامر هو انه
استهل الموسم باخراجه من مباراه ضد
بورتموث بعد ان نطح الخصم براسه وعوقب
بالحظر لثلاث مباريات لكنه تحول الى موسم
مذهل بعد ذلك فور عودته بعد الحظر سجل
هدفه الاول للموسم في لشبونه ضد سبورتنج
وهو ناديه الاول في دوري الابطال وبعد ذلك
اخذ يحرز الاهداف كل اسبوع تقريبا مسجلا
42 هدفا مع يونايتد في ذلك الموسم
والهاتريك الاول له مع النادي اخذ يحطم
الارقام القياسيه في شتى النواحي وفي خضم
هذه الحمله المبهره التي شهدنا فيها تطور
اللاعب اكثر فاكثر ترددت الهمسات الاولى
في شان ريال مدريد
[موسيقى]
كان نادي مانشستر يونايتد في خضم التغلب
على رقم ليفربول القياسي لعدد الالقاب
المحليه في الدوري الانجليزي الممتاز
وبالطبع فرضت المنافسه المحتدمه بين
ناديين فوزهما في كاس اوروبا ومحاوله
اغلاق الفجوه بين مانشستر يونايتد
وليفربول فيما يتعلق بعدد الانتصارات في
كاس اوروبا ودوري الابطال لذا اصبح الامر
مصب تركيز فيرجسون لم يكونوا قد فازوا
بدوري الابطال منذ عام
1999 وكان رونالدو متنبها الى حقيقه انه
لن يعتبر كواحدا من اعظم اللاعبين في
العالم ما لم يكن في حوزته فوز بدوري
الابطال
وشعر حتما بسعاده شخصيه عارمه بعد التغلب
على ميسي الذي يلعب مع فريق برشلونه في
مواجهه الذهاب والاياب في نصف النهائي ثم
ذهبوا الى موسكو لمواجهه تشيلسي في
النهائي وكان نادي تشيلسي انذاك الفريق
الجديد البارز فيما يتعلق بدعامه كره
القدم الانجليزيه حيث كان الرومان
ابرموفيتش يمول النادي وكان ناديا عظيما
بالفعل
بالنسبه الى المباراه كانت طرفان يعرف
احدهما الاخر حق المعرفه وربما في شكل
حتمي رونالدو هو الذي كسر التعادل مانحا
مانشستر الصداره لكن فريق تشيلسي قوي وسدد
فرانك لامبارد هدف التعادل من جديد وكان
الفريقان على سويه واحده بالفعل استمرت
المباراه حتى الليل حين حقق مانشستر الفوز
اخيرا بالركلات الترجيحيه اصبح في امكان
رونالدو الاحتفال كفائزا في دوري الابطال
لكنه كان لاعب مانشستر الوحيد الذي اخفق
في التسديد الامر الذي من المرجح انه كدر
صفوه في تلك الامسيه الى حد ما
صد الكره
تمت امور مقدره الحصول فحسب
الرجل الذي لم يتوقف عن احراز الاهداف
طوال الموسم قد توقف في منتصف الركض ونجح
بيتر تشيك في صد الكره لكنه حصل على
ميداليه الفوز في دوري الابطال اخيرا وحصل
مانشستر على الكاس للمره الاولى منذ عقدا
تقريبا
كانت مسيرته مع يونايتد في ازدهار وبفضل
ادائه الاستثنائي في موسم 2007 2008 فاز
رونالدو بجائزه الكره الذهبيه الاولى
ليصنف اخيرا كافضل لاعب في العالم
لكن في صدى فوزه بجائزه الكره الذهبيه
ولعبه المذهل في الملعب بدات الشائعه
تنتشر في خصوص رغبه رونالدو بالانتقال من
النادي اعلن ان نادي مانشستر سيتي الذي
كان تحت ملكيه جديده حينها يسعى الى شرائه
المال ليس معضله بالنسبه اليكم ماذا ان
اصبح رونالدو متاحا فهو يلعب حاليا مع
اكبر منافسيكم مانشستر يونايتد هل ستدفعون
70 او 80 او 100 مليون جنيه استرليني
مقابل سيتخذ هذا القرار بالاشتراك مع مدير
النادي مارك هيوز اذا اراد مدير النادي دم
رونالدو الى مانشستر سيتي
سنؤمن التمويل بين اسهم راس المال والفرق
هل ستدفعون 60 او 70 مليون جنيه استرليني
مقابل يعتمد الامر على استحقاقه للمبلغ
اذا كان يستحق سندفع لكن نفر رونالدو هذه
الشائعه سريعا حيث صرح انه لن يغادر ناديه
السؤال الاخير لي هل ستبقى مع مانشستر
يونايتد ام ان الشائعات عن مغازاتك
الصحيحه في اعتقادك من سيلعب مع فريق
مدريد العام المقبل
ثم حمقى في هذا المكان اليس كذلك ظنتك قلت
متى كانوا في ناديه
ان اردتني ان اراهن على ذلك ساراهن جدا
على نفسي واعتقد انه اذا كان اللاعب
سيغادر اولد ترافورد ويغادر مانشستر واراد
الذهاب الى نادي افضل وهذا قابل للجدال
تمت خيار واحد وهو ريال مدريد وكان ذلك
مغريا جدا لدرجه ان رونالدو كان مهتما
بذلك رامون كالديرون سعيت بشده للحصول على
رونالدو وتقول انك لم تعد تسعى للتوقيع
معها هل تطمئن مشجعي مانشستر يونايتد انك
لن تسعى للحصول عليه عندما يفتح باب
الانتقال من جديد لا قلت ان كريستيانو
رونالدو قرر البقاء مع مانشستر يونايتد
وقرر ليونايتد الا يبيع اللاعب وهذا كل
شيء لا يمكننا فعل اي شيء في خصوص ذلك
هذا يحصل مع لاعبينا ايضا ترغب نواه اخرى
بالحصول على العديد من لاعبينا لكن يغلق
النقاش في حال لم يريدوا المغادره ولم نرد
البيع لم تعد تريد الحصول عليه اذا
نحن نرغب بالحصول على اي لاعب بارع في
العالم مثل ما يرغب مانشستر بالحصول على
اي لاعب بارع ليس فقط من ريال مدريد بل من
جميع ارجاء العالم ايضا لكن اعتقد ان
الاتفاق يجب ان يتم بين النادي واللاعب في
العام 2019 تحولت الشائعات الى حقيقه تم
الاتفاق على نقل رونالدو الى ريال مدريد
مقابل مبلغ كليا قدره 80 مليون جنيه
استرليني ليصبح حينها اغلى لاعبا تم شرائه
في تاريخ كره القدم تصدر الانتقال
العناوين في العالم وبدا رونالدو سعيدا
ومتحمسا للعب مع الفريق الحاصل على 31
لقبا للدوري الاسباني واحد اثنان
بينما يقدم رونالدو افضل اداء بحسب قدراته
وفي جعبته اكثر من 33 هدفا في الموسم
انتهى اول موسم له دون احراز اي كاس ولا
كره ذهبيه ولا كاس الدوري الاسباني ولا
كاس دوري ابطال اوروبا اذ خسر الكؤوس
الثلاثه امام برشلونه وولدهم الذهبي ميسي
لكن بدخول موسم 2010 2011 عاد رونالدو الى
عادته في الفوز بجائزه الكره الذهبيه والى
ارتداء القميص ذي الرقم 7 بعد مغادره
راؤول في نهايه الموسم المنصرم شعر
رونالدو بان ريال مدريد بيته الجديد
وساعده ذلك الانتقال على تطوير مهاراته في
جوانب اللعبه كافه
استعد دوما بالطريقه نفسها لا يهمني ضد اي
فريق سالعب يبقى تركيزي هو نفسه
ربما حين العب ضد اكبر الفرق تكون الحماسه
لدي اعلى قليلا لكن الامر سيان اركز
ذهنيا دوما على تقديم افضل ما لدي لم يكن
يتطور فقط من ناحيه مهاراته بل بدا موقفه
خلال المباريات يتغير ايضا قد يفعل
رونالدو في سن اصغر اشياء قد تسبب طرده او
قد تبدو سخيفه قليلا لكنه نال بطاقات
حمراء وتسبب في عثرات لم تبدو ضروريه
احيانا لكن حين صار يقود ريال مدريد
ومنتخب البرتغال تحمل المسؤوليه المرافقه
لذلك ليس فقط واحده من اروع لاعبي كره
القدم في العالم ربما هو اعظم لاعب انه
مثل روجيه فيديرير واحد من اعظم رياضي
العالم ينظر الناس حول العالم اليه باعجاب
سواء اكانوا من محبي كره القدم ام لا وهو
معروف في ارجاء العالم ويحمل كريستيانو
رونالدو ذلك بكل تاكيد لست قلقا لان هذا
يحدث بالعاده لن اتكلم عن تجاوزات برشلونه
ولا المهمات المستحيله لان الامر لا يهمني
ما يهم الان ان لدينا مباراه غدا وان
ربحنا
فسنستمر وان خسرنا فسنعود للمنزل انا
متفائل اننا سنربح المباراه وسنربحها
بالتاكيد في موسم
2012-13 وصل ريال مدريد الى نصف نهائي
دوري الابطال واجهوا مانشستر يونايتد
وكانت المره الاولى لرونالدو يواجه فيها
ناديه القديم
واضح ان رونالدو قد عاد ولعب واحرز
الاهداف حين كان لاعبا في صفوف مانشستر
وكان حتميا عاجلا ام اجلا سيواجه
اليونايتد ريال مدريد وسيتحتم على رونالدو
ان يواجه اليكس فيرجس الذي يمكن له
احتراما كبيرا وقد لعب في ملعب اولدي
ترافورد بقميص ريال مدريد في ربيع عام
2013 خلال بطوله دوري ابطال اوروبا في
دوري 16 تغلب ريال مدريد على مانشستر بهدف
في ملعب برنابيو وقد سجل رونالدو الهدف
طبعا ثم في مباراه الاياب في الاولدر فورد
كانت مباراه مثيره للجدال كان لاعبون
مانشستر غير راضيين عن الحكم ومن يسجل هدف
الفوز لريال مدريد انه كريستيانو رونالدو
لم يحتفل امام مشجعي مانشستر لانني اظن
انه جزء منه ويحمل احتراما كبيرا لهم لكنه
حريص على فوز فريقه الحالي
يستدير اوزيل ثم يمرر يرسل هيغوايين كره
عرضيه ويتقدم ريال مدريد يعود كريستيانو
رونالدو لاحتفال بالهدف رغم النتائج
الرائعه لريال مدريد كانت المباراه عرضا
حقيقيا لنبل اخلاق رونالدو وحساسيته اتجاه
ناديه القديم عام 2014 تابع ريال مدريد
فوزه بهدفين مقابل لا شيء في كاس السوبر
الاوروبيه ضد اشبيليه احرز رونالدو
الهدفين لمدريد وحصل على جائزه رجل
المباراه التي سلمها
في مباريات كهذه من الصعب دوما اختيار رجل
المباراه ثم تلاعبون جيدون كثر في الملعب
لكن كريستيانو جعل الاختيار سهلا علي
الليله
اشكر السير اليكس فيريكسون على منح هذه
الكاس وهي تعني للكثير لانه كان المدرب
الذي علمني اشياء عده حين كنت في صفوف
مانشستر يونايتد في سن الثامنه عشره لذا
اقدر ذلك لك واشكرك على منح هذه الكاس
خلال سنوات القليله التاليه ابحر رونالدو
نجم مدريد وبقي يحطم الارقام القياسيه مع
النادي محققا علامات فارقه ومستمتعا بكل
مباراه لعبها وبعدما اصبح مجددا مسجله
اكبر عدد اهداف في دوري الابطال
2013-14 امسى بسهوله افضل لاعب في العالم
لا تتحقق الانجازات الاستثنائيه لرونالدو
بسهوله يجب ان يكون في لياقه بدنيه فائقه
لذلك وبالطبع كان رونالدو دائما اهلا لها
وفي اواخر العشرينات من عمره كان في افضل
حاله اقوى واسرع مما كان عليه يوما وكان
يحطم الارقام القياسيه في الميمنه
والميسره والوسط احرز مئه هدف لريال مدريد
في مباريات الدوري في شكل اسرع مما حققه
فرنش بوشكاش محطما رقمه القياسي الذي ظل
صامدا عقودا من الزمن من حقبه كان فيها
احراز الاهداف اسهل بكثير مما في العصر
الحديث سجل 200 هدف لريال مدريد في 197
مباراه انها ارقام متعاقبه مدهشه ومذهله
بينما تتهاوى الارقام القياسيه امام مجهود
كريستيانو رونالدو البطولي في نادي ضم بعض
اروع اللاعبين الذين رايناهم يوما وربما
باتوا يحظون باعظم لاعب في تاريخ النادي
رقم ستيفانو القياسي ورقم بوشكاش القياسي
وهو ما زال يحرز الاهداف لم يتعرض لاي
اصابه ويلعب اسبوعيا هو وميسي شخصان
مدهشان من خلال هذا التحدي الدائم
للمستحيل فقط ومن خلال الموهبه والاصرار
يمكن الوصول الى الابديه وهذا ما فعله
كريستيانو رونالدو منذ هذا الاسبوع
كريستيانو رونالدو هو الهداف الافضل طوال
تاريخ ريال مدريد الحافل
324 هدفا خلال 380 مباريات وهذا متوقع من
قبله والمعجبون يزدادون كل يوم وهذا
اللاعب يحاول ان يصبح افضل وهو دائما يعد
بان يكرس حياته للعبه وبالا يتركها وان
يناضل دوما في سبيل الفوز الى ريال مدريد
لم اكن اخطط ابدا ولكن عندما ارتديت للمره
الاولى قامص ريال مدريد وصممت ان اكون
افضل هداف بتاريخ النادي الاعرق والاكبر
في العالم
واستطعت منافسه صديقي راؤول والمرحوم الف
رينو استفانو لذلك اريد ان اقول انني في
الحقيقه فخور بالفريق
منذ تولي بيلغريني الذي طور ريال مدريد
حتى مورينيو وتشيلوته والان
بنيستي وبفضلهم ايضا
لانهم ساعدوني في مسيرتي لكن الى جانب
مسيرته مع ريال مدريد كان ايضا اللاعب
النجمه لمنتخب البرتغال المشارك في بطولتي
كاس العالم واوروبا اعطي دور قائد الفريق
خلال افضل مواسمه في مانشستر يونايتد وكان
يعد القدوه لجميع اللاعبين وصولا الى
بطوله اوروبا 2016 ساعد دوره في الفريق
على اجتياز الطريق نحو النهائي ومواجهه
فرنسا لكنها لم تكن مباراه يسيره على
رونالدو بل كانت في الحقيقه من اشدها وطاه
عليه على الاطلاق في سن صغيره جدا حين كان
رونالدو مشاركا مع منتخب البرتغال لبطوله
امم اوروبا لعام 2004 حين خسر النهائيه
على ارضهم عام 2012 بلغوا نصف النهائي
وامست تلك المباراه نقطه سوداء في مسيره
رونالدو الدوليه في نصف النهائي في دوناتك
حين لجاوا الى ركلات الترجيح امام اسبانيا
وقد انبرر رونالدو لتنفيذ الركله الاخيره
لكن لان زملائه ضيعوا رك لاتهم لم تصل
البرتغال الى لاعب الركله الاخيره خسروا
ركلات الترجيح امام اسبانيا حتى قبل ان
ينفذ رونالدو ركلاته
[تصفيق]
بفارق بسيط تنتقل اسبانيا الى المباراه
النهائيه مجددا يبدون اول فريق يدافع عن
هذه الكاس كانت خيبه امل كبرى بقميص
المنتخب الوطني ثم في امم اوروبا 2016
وصلت البرتغال الى النهائي في مواجهه
فرنسا واعتقد الجميع انها ستكون اللحظه
التي سيلمع فيها رونالدو مع منتخب بلاده
على المسرح الكبير ليكسب كاسا للبرتغال
للمره الاولى بوجوده معهم ثم اصيب في
بدايه المباراه
[تصفيق]
تقرا علامات الحزن في وجهه عمل بجد وانتظر
طويلا ليبلغ هذه اللحظه ويلعب النهائي مع
منتخب بلاده وحين يتم ذلك يستمر بضع دقائق
فقط تشعر بان رونالدو مرغوب فيه دوما ان
يكون الرجل الذي يدير العرض وعمليا ينتهي
به المطاف بتدريب الفريق حتى انه يكاد ان
يلبس معطف المدير الفني على خط الملعب
ويقودهم الى النصر على فرنسا في النهائي
وفي شكل مذهل من دون رونالدو في الملعب بل
بتوجيهاته من مقاعد الكادر التدريبي يغدو
المنتخب البرتغالي بطل اوروبا انه الحلم
الذي تحقق بطريقه لم يتصورها احد
لكنها اعظم ليله في تاريخ البرتغال الكروي
لرونالدو من الدموع الى الاهازيج والمزيد
من الدموع لكنها دموع الفرح هذه المره
انها الكاس الكبرى الاولى لهم رغم
الصعوبات كلها
بفضل اداء البرتغال المتكامل خلال البطوله
تابع رونالدو طريقه للفوز بجائزه الحذاء
الفضي محرزا ثلاثه اهداف وساهم في ثلاثه
في البطوله لحظه تاريخيه له اذا ضاف كاسا
اخرى الى مجموعته كما ساعد بلده ليصبح
افضل فريق في اوروبا قاطبه
لست راضيا ولكنني دائما اعرف انني الوحيد
الذي اريد المزيد حصلت على اربع جوائز
واريد الجائزه الخامسه انوي الحصول على
مجموعه الحذاء الذهبي كامله وهذه الجوائز
اضافيه لريال مدريد كاكبر نادي في العالم
ويجب ان يربح الالقاب في كل عام تابع
رونالدو التقديم عروض مذهله مع ريال مدريد
ومهاراته تتطور في شكل متواصل وقد تطور
ليصبح لاعبا اساسيا في الفريق بفضل مواسم
رائعه واصل رونالدو الفوز باربع جوائز كره
ذهبيه اخرى ليصل الى رقم قياسيا بخمس
جوائز وهو رقم حققه مره واحده فقط قبله
خصمه اللدود ومنافسه في الدوري الاسباني
ليونيل ميسي
الفائز هو كريستيانو رونالدو
[تصفيق]
حين ذكروا الاسم في البدايه بدا قلبي يخفق
بسرعه وازداد توتر انها لحظه صعبه بصراحه
لكن اعتقد انني استحقها نوير يستحقها ايضا
وكذلك ميسي لكنني كنت الاحق بها السنه
الماضيه لذا انا مسرور جدا بذلك
انه احد افضل اللاعبين على مر الزمان ولا
احد يستطيع قول غير ذلك انه من افضل
اللاعبين على مر العصور بكل بساطه
يقولون انه افضل لاعب في العالم ويتناقشون
في شان بيليه مارادونا ولابد من وجودهما
في المعادله لانهما كان لاعبين مذهلين لكن
اعتقد ان الجدير بالقول ان بيليه لم
ينافسه لاعبون معاصرون وكذلك
في ظل غياب منافسين يتحدونهما اما رونالدو
فينافسه ميسي وميسي ينافسه رونالدو وقد
ساعد ذلك كليهما
وكان سجالا سنويا لاعوام متلاحقه عندما
يحين موعد جائزه الكره الذهبيه رونالدو ام
ميسي وكل محبا لكره القدم في العالم له
راي في ذلك وقد يتغير ذلك الراي لان
الاداء والنجاح متبادلان بينهما لكن
الحقيقه ان كل منهما احرز خمس جوائز كره
ذهبيه لم يفترق مطلقا حين يتقدم احدهما
يتمكن الاخر من مطاردته وتقليص الفارق
ويبدو مناسبا الحصول كل منهما على خمس
منها على الرغم من ان رونالدو معروف
بلاعبه لفريق ريال مدريد انتشرت شائعه من
جديد بانه يتطلع الى الانتقال الى نادي
اخر لا احد يدري
الله وحده يعلم لا اعلم ما يخبئه المستقبل
لكنني سعيد جدا مع ريال مدريد لا احد يدري
مع انتهاء عقده عام 2018 كانت مساله وقت
فحسب قبل ان يعرف الجمهور مكان مخبا
للفائز بجائزه الكره الذهبيه خمس مرات انا
اشعر بالراحه في نادي ريال مدريد
واريد البقاء فيه واما عن النادي الايطالي
فلا ادري ايهما افضل اكثر لالعب فيه
ولكنني احترمهم كثيرا لديهم لاعبون
مخضرمون ودفاع الايطالي يقويون ويصعب
اختراقه ولكن ربما في المستقبل لا احد
يعرف لا اعرف لكن قبل انتهاء مده عقده
واجه ريال مدريد فريق يوفنتوس في ربع
نهائي دوري الابطال خلال تلك المباراه سجل
رونالدو احد ابرز الاهداف التي راها احد
على الاطلاق
يستمر تقديم عرضا حقيقيا لافضل اهداف
رونالدو مرارا وتكرارا لكن هناك هدف يبرز
ربما فوق بقيه الاهداف وذلك في تورينو ضد
يوفنتوس في ربع نهائي دوري الابطال لعام
2018 ويصفه
الايطالي الرائع بانه من اهداف لعبه بلاي
ستيشن
ركله مقصيه مزدوجه انفجاريه تمثل خلاصه
المهاره الرياضيه بتوقع مذهل وبدهاء وجراه
مطلقه
ثم رونالدو
يا له من هدف كريستيانو رونالدو مذهل
اروع رياضي في تاريخ دوري الابطال
بجمال مطلق قليل من اللاعبين يمكنهم تخيل
ذلك الهدف واقل منهم قد يحاولون تسجيله
وربما واحد فقط سيسجله وقد سجله رونالدو
ركله مقصيه خلفيه لا تصدق ووقف مشجع
يوفنتوس للتصفيق له انه مزيج مذهل من
الرؤيه والتقنيه والمهاره الرياضيه
والجراه المطلقه
لم ارى قط جمهورا يصفق واقفا لافضل لاعب
لدى الخصم يحرز هدفا كهذا
وحتى رونالدو نفسه يقول انه افضل هدف سجله
في حياته حتى الان بعد تلك المباراه بدا
يوفنتوس محادثات مع ريال مدريد ورونالدو
في شان عقده وبعد ذلك لاستقبال الحميمي له
في يوفنتوس خلال مباراه دوري الابطال صرح
رونالدو رائع بقاعده مشجعين محبين للغايه
لكن مع اقتراب انتهاء مده عقد رونالدو
اسيكون يوفنتوس محطته الجديده مايو من عام
2018 محطه بارزه في مسيره رونالدو لعب
ريال مدريد ضد ليفربول في نهائي دوري
الابطال في كييف وهزموهم بثلاثه اهداف
لهدف احرز رونالدو خمسه عشره هدفا في دوري
الابطال لذلك الموسم للموسم السادس على
التوالي هو الهداف الاول في المنافسه مع
احراز كاس دوري الابطال اخرى لريال مدريد
وهي خامس بطوله دوري ابطال لرونالدو وهذا
رقم قياسي ثم بعد المباراه يشير الى المده
التي قضاها في النادي مستخدما الزمن
الماضي وكان صدمه لريال مدريد لان رونالدو
كان يف كر في الانتقال واتذكر انني كنت في
روسيا كانت مرحله نصف نهائي والنهائي في
نهايات كاس العالم لعام 2018 وكانت وسائل
الاعلام الكرويه العالميه كلها هناك وقد
ابهر رونالدو ابصار الجميع لان الاخبار
المفاجئه لم تعد حول روسيا ولا كاس العالم
بل عن تورينو لان رونالدو انضم الى صفوف
يوفنتوس
ايا يكن الدافع الانتقاله من مدريد الى
يوفنتوس فمعناه ان رونالدو يستطيع احراز
ارقام قياسيه جديده فاصبح انتقالا تاريخيا
الى ايطاليا سجل رقما قياسيا في انتقال
لاعب فوق سن الثلاثين فكان في الثلاثه من
العمر لكنه يحافظ على لياقه مذهله طبعا
واصبح مع يوفنتوس اول لاعب يفوز بلقب
الدوري في انجلترا واسبانيا وايطاليا
وتشعر بان رونالدو يجد ارقاما قياسيه
يستطيع تحطيمها ويوفنتوس المكان المناسب
لذلك
لسوء حظ رونالدو تعكر اول اداء له في دوري
الابطال مع يوفنتوس بتعرضه لطرد مثير
للجدال
لكن حتى بعدما مر به في مسيرته ما زالت
لدى رونالدو تلك النزعه الى المشاكسه وقد
رايناه في ظهوره الاول في دوري الابطال مع
يوفنتوس ضد فالنسيا حين تعرض للطرد على ما
يبدو بسبب شد شعر
قد يكون رونالدو في مازق رونالدو في ورطه
كبيره هذا دوري الابطال سيتصدر الخبر
العناوين العوده الاولى لرونالدو الى
اسبانيا منذ قياده ريال مدريد تشهد طرد
مسجل الارقام القياسيه في دوري الابطال
الاوروبي تحطم رونالدو تماما وغادر الملعب
باكيا كانت لحظه مهوله في مسيرته الواعده
مع يوفنتوس تلك اول بطاقه حمراء ينالها في
دوري الابطال لكنها الحاديه عشره في
مسيرته الرياضيه هناك لحظات في مسيرته
يعود فيها رونالدو ذلك الطفل المتهور الذي
لعب في صفوف مانشستر يونايتد لكن رغم تلك
اللحظه المثيره للجدال ظل رونالدو يقدم
اداء عالميا المستوى ظل يسجل الاهداف بين
اسبوع واخر وحضوره يجذب حشود المعجبين في
اي مكان يقصده في تشرين الثاني عام 2019
سجل رونالدو ثلاثيه اخرى للبرتغال في
التصفيات المؤهله لبطوله امم اوروبا 2020
تضاف الى انجازاته مع منتخب بلاده يريد
ذلك رونالدو
وقد سجل الثلاثيه
[تصفيق]
كانت كره حتميه
يتصدر النجم عناوين الاخبار مجددا
يجدر القول ان رونالدو هو اللاعب الاكثر
شعبيه في هذه الرياضه ويحظى بسهوله باضخم
قاعده معجبين بين جميع اللاعبين في العالم
لكنه ليس لعب كره قدم محبوبا فحسب بل هو
ايضا رجل اعمال ذكي منذ ان كان في مانشستر
يونايتد انخرط رونالدو في صفقات تجاريه
عده في اشاره الى شركته الاسطوريه سي ار 7
فقد اطلق عطورا وظهر على واجهه العاب
الفيديو المرتبطه بكره القدم ويمتلك خطه
التجاريه لصناعه الالبسه الداخليه كذلك
لديه علاماته التجاريه في مجال الملابس
ما هي رائحه كريستيانو رونالدو حسن في
الحقيقه احب دائما ان تكون الرائحه جميله
وهذه تجربه الثالثه هذا العطر رائحته
ناعمه وخفيفه
ويمكنك ان تتخيلي كم انا سعيد فالرائحه
فواحه لا اعرف اذا شممت رائحه العطر اذا
انه نعم انا احبه كثيرا واصبح اكثر من
لاعب كره قدم خلال عقدين من الزمن صار
تقريبا علامه تجاريه بتلك الوقفه الشهيره
قبل تنفيذه ركله حره على اعلانات عطور سي
ار 7 والمتحف في جزيرته في ماديرا وكل ما
يحيط برونالدو وقد اعتنق ذلك فهو رجل
استعراضي ورجل اعمال محنك وهو يفهم حتما
اهميه موقعه ضمن نجوميه العالم
ما الهدف من الاستثمار في هذا
المشروب حسن في الحقيقه انها فرصه كبيره
وجميله
فالمجال الصحي يعنيني كثيرا علينا بذل كل
الامكانات والجهود للاستثمار في هذا
المجال
وشريكي ايضا يساعدني ويعجبه هذا المشروع
وهو شخص لديه رؤيه عالميه وانا سعيد جدا
بشراكه معه انه مميز وعلاوه على ذلك يقدم
الكثير من الدعم للمجتمعات الفقيره منذ
عام 2014 عمل رونالدو بالتعاون مع منظمه
سيف ذا تشيلدرين لمساعده الاطفال الذين
عانوا من الحروب او اصيبوا بامراض خطيره
في ارجاء العالم كذلك صار سفيرا للمنظمه
وواصل اجراء الحملات لهم في شكل منتظم
[موسيقى]
كما يتبرع رونالدو بمكافاته الكرويه
للجمعيات الخيريه التي يختارها عام 2013
تمت تسميه رونالدو في صفوف فريق العام
للاتحاد الاوروبي لكره القدم وحقق له ذلك
89 الف جنيه تم تقديم هذا المال مباشره
الى جمعيه الصليب الاحمر الخيريه كذلك نال
مكافاه قدرها 450 الف جنيه تبرع بها لسيف
وورد فيجن ثلاثه منظمات خيريه هو سفيرها
[موسيقى]
ممنوع ان يجروا خلفك اذا تجاوزتها هؤلاء
الاطفال العشرين حسنا جرب حظك هيا بنا هيا
[موسيقى]
حسنا انها فرصه لدعم الطبيعه حدث هذا
عندما ولدت في موطني وهذا الموقف معقد
بالنسبه الى الناس الذين يعيشون هناك
الشيء الوحيد الذي يمكنني قوله عليهم
الاستمرار في العمل والنضال لتتحسن
الاوضاع والا يفقد الامل اعرف انه موقف
معقد بالنسبه الى العائلات والاشخاص
والاولاد ولكن الكلمه الوحيده الان هي
التحلي بالصبر
[موسيقى]
تصعب معرفه متى سيتوقف رونالدو في النهايه
سيتوقف حتما في مرحله ما كما يقول هو
بنفسه يعتقد ان امامه اربعه او خمسه او
سته مواسم لانه حافظ على لياقه بدنيه
عاليه وممتازه فجسده جسد شاب اصغر سنا وقد
يكون محقا في ذلك لا اراه ينهي رحلته في
نادي صغير في البرتغال فتخيل له توقفا
مفاجئا وحينها سيدرك العالم انه فقد
بالتاكيد واحدا من افضل ثلاثه او اربعه
لاعبين على الاطلاق
سيتم تذكره دوما بانه احد اعظم لاعب كره
القدم على مر العصور وحتى حين يعتزل اللعب
سيميز محب كره القدم علامته التجاريه سي
ار 7 وسيعرفون دائما اسماء كريستيانو
رونالدو
اعتقد ان رونالدو وعلينا ذكر ميسي قد غير
طريقه دعم ناشئه لكره القدم في صغر ربما
كنا ندعم فريقنا المحلي ثم مؤخرا ربما
تشجع اكبر الفرق في بلدك خلال طفولتك
والان اعتقد ان الاطفال في انحاء العالم
في سن العاشره يقولون انهم يشجعون ريال
مدريد بسبب رونالدو او يشجعون برشلونه
بسبب ميسي لقد قسم الاطفال الى طوابير
المشجعين في العالم اما ان تكون في صف
رونالدو او ميسي واما انك مع ريال مدريد
او برشلونه ولا يهم ان كنت في مانشستر او
سان بطرسبورغ او مدريد او مالومو اما انك
مع ريال مدريد واما مع برشلونه بسبب
رونالدو او ميسي
انا سعيد للغايه بوجود هنا مع هؤلاء
اللاعبين وهذا المدرب لانها فرصه رائعه لي
ساتعلم شيئا جديدا دوما واريد مواصله
مسيرتي هكذا سنه تلو الاخرى
[موسيقى]